what's up guys and girls raj here back
with another video
so how do you collect interview
questions for your upcoming interview
and once you know the questions how do
you prepare for them
so in this quick video i'm gonna go over
some tips and tricks that you can use
and i have personally used these tips
and tricks for many of my interviews so
they are battle tested so all right
let's get started
so once you know the position
for the interview such as devops
engineer solutions architect network
engineer etc
you go to glassdoor and then you just
search for that position
so let's say in this case
we are looking for devops engineer
and then select devops engineer
interviews
then you will see bunch of sample
questions for different companies
so what i do is
i will copy paste all these interview
questions right so it's a little tedious
but
that's the only way to do this uh and
then i'll go through these different
pages
and copy paste all the questions
and in some cases i will also check the
answer like in some cases the person
will also give the answer i'll copy
paste those as well
so after you do this there will be some
duplicate questions like some questions
that's appearing such as what is awk in
linux
it might come later on the fifth page as
well right
so i will go through the questions and
dedupe them
and then prepare the answers
for the questions that
glassdoor did not have answers for
and another thing
i would do is
i try to think of the follow-up
questions so let's say for this question
uh what you know about jenkins so you
might prepare for jenkins what is
jenkins how does it work etc
but i would also try to think of some of
the other questions that could come up
from this such as
what are some of the challenges of using
jenkins or
have you used any newer devops tools
such as azure devops or aws code
pipeline or maybe gitlab etc so that's
how i will collect the list of the
questions
think about the follow-up questions or
the other questions that could come up
from them and prepare
so another tool at your disposal is
actually linkedin interview so this is a
newer feature
so when i was giving my interview at aws
this was not there
so if you go to linkedin
let me make a little bigger
and select this
jobs
icon
and see this interview prep on the side
so this is a new addition so you click
this interview prep
and see there are different categories
so these are some of the common
questions such as tell me about yourself
what is your greatest strength etc
if you click categories it also has
other categories such as software
engineer project manager etc
so you can select any of the category
and then it is also gonna
show you sample answers from other folks
so to see the full answers
you need to have linkedin premium
so generally a linkedin premium
gives you one month of free trial so do
this when you are serious like don't do
this if you just want to know but when
you are really preparing for interviews
and stuff
you unlock the premium for a month and
then you can go check
the all the answers for all these
questions
so another feature that linkedin now has
is
you can also send
your answer to uh some experts and they
will give feedback on it
so let's say
you want to practice the answer about
tell me about a time you managed a
project
so you can just click
practice and get feedback and you can
record a video of your answer of
yourself
or you can write a response and then you
send it to linkedin and they will give
feedback about that
by the way i'm not affiliated with
linkedin okay linkedin didn't give me
any money to
to to tell this about but i'm just
saying this is pretty helpful
and some of these answers are pretty
good
i did have premium for a little bit uh
so i did check after but this is after i
went through all the interviews i
already have the job and everything uh
so yeah some of these answers are pretty
good you can see the number of views
like 4 000 views on this this answer
454 views on this one
etc that's it really i wanted to make a
quick and short video on uh how to get
different interview questions and how do
i prepare for those uh hopefully this
was helpful
all right guys and girls uh please uh
click
like subscribe comment on the video do
all the youtube stuff uh that's it for
this one i'll see you guys and girls in
the next video bye